for more on all of this let's bring in
Carolina South Carolina Congresswoman
Nancy mace she serves on uh the armed
services and house oversight and
accountability committees do you have
anything to tell us about what's in this
bill uh by any chance you know more than
Chad does about what's coming out of the
Senate we're waiting on Chad to give us
the information and the text of the bill
we don't yet have the text of the bill
but with the rumors we've been hearing
is that this will be Mass amnesty 5,000
illegal immigrants a day compared to
10,000 right now anything short of
shutting down the Border shutting down
free hotel rooms shutting down free
credit cards for illegal aliens that are
coming into this country anything short
of that is going to have problems in the
house because I can tell you right now
uh folks on both sides out when I talk
to voters and constituents throughout
South Carolina both Democrats and
Republicans are frustrated with Joe
Biden's posturing on this they're
frustrated with the amount of free money
free education free healthare these
illegals are getting they're being
encouraged to come into this country
Americans are angry and by what's
happening in this country they're angry
at the Biden Administration anything shy
of shutting it down until we resolve the
situation isn't going to pass muster for
a lot of America right now and I'm
seeing it on the ground here in South
Carolina and you're hearing about it in
sanctuary cities across the country
right now people are angry that Joe
Biden has allowed this to happen to our
country and the Speaker of the House
Mike Johnson says that uh he hasn't even
seen any uh of this bill that he hasn't
been brought in on the negotiations that
doesn't seem like a way to get a bill
passed into
law well that's the senate for you we we
have given them hr2 we have given the
Senate border security measures we've
gave them a Homeland Security bill with
border security in it we've given them
all these things and yet they want to
start from scratch they want to start
with mass amnesty and that does not work
for the vast majority of Americans
regardless if you have an r or a d by
your name and so I hope that Republicans
will find a backbone that we will hold
the line and be strong on this because
we know that the majority of our country
is with us there there doesn't need to
be another bill we need the president to
follow the laws on the books we need the
president to go back to Donald Trump's
border security policies continue
building the wall title 42 remain in
Mexico and tell these people we are not
open there is no other country in the
world that has a wide openen border like
we do this would not stand in any other
Nation around the world but because Joe
Biden is in charge somehow it's okay
it's not okay with the vast majority of
Americans well some Democrats are saying
that look Joe Biden's numbers are
terrible on this the American people as
you have said don't approve of the job
he's doing on the border and so they
blame Republicans such as yourself for
trying to Stonewall this border be deal
uh deal because they say that uh they
don't want Joe Biden having a victory
ahead of the election they don't want
his border numbers in other words to
improve and there there are the uh Biden
versus Trump issues uh the numbers on
issues border security Trump gets a 57%
positive rating Joe Biden's is 22% I
know that's a long-winded question
congresswoman but maybe you can try and
pull an answer out for me well well you
know me I've always called it like I see
it regardless if you're republican or
democrat or independent this is not
about personality this is about policy
and our border was more secure with
Donald Trump's policies when he was
president and that's what Americans are
seeing just yesterday you saw 50 Cent uh
weigh in that maybe Donald Trump is the
answer because he's seeing what's going
on in New York City we're seeing what's
going on in Chicago we're seeing what's
going on in sanctuary cities around the
nation you just had mayor Eric Adams in
New York uh put together a massive
multi-million dollar deal for illegal
immigrants giving him credit cards and
cash in New York City when they came
here they came here breaking the law
this does not sit well with the vast
majority of Americans which is why I
we're not stonewalling here I just want
the president to follow our laws in my
district in South Carolina's first
congressional district we have a border
Training Academy here we are training
our border patrol agents we want them to
be safe and secure we want the president
of the United States to put our nation
and her Citizens First follow our laws
that is it that at the very end of the
day that's it we don't need another bill
we just want Joe Biden to follow the
laws that's what needs to happen here
does the impeachment effort against the
homeland security secretary does that do
you think send a message to the White
House well absolutely and he needs to go
he's not been honest with Congress in
the hearings and in his testimony and at
the end of the day someone has to take
responsibility for the mess of the
Southern border and if Joe Biden won't
then sen then secretary my orcus will
have to uh that's what the American
people want that's what they deserve and
that's what we should deliver
Congresswoman Nancy ma Republican of
South Carolina congresswoman thank you
thank you hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now